we're on problem
154
154.
they ask us is x negative so the
question is is x less than zero
statement number one tells us
let's see they say x to the third times
one minus
x squared is less than zero and let's
simplify let's say x to the third
minus x to the fifth is less than zero
let's see we could add x to the fifth to
both sides x to the third is less than x
to the fifth
let's divide both sides by x squared and
that won't change the inequality since x
squared is definitely going to be
positive any integer squared even if
it's negative is positive so you divide
both sides by x squared you get x
is less than x to the third
now let's see does this answer that
question or let's see what x's would
satisfy this condition
so this is definitely if you think of
so x we can already say that x cannot be
equal to zero
right
we anything where this would have been
inequality doesn't work x can't be equal
to zero it can't be equal to one because
one is equal to one third and it can't
be equal to negative one so we we know
that immediately
we know that for regular positive
numbers for numbers greater than one
for numbers greater than one taking it
to the third power is always going to be
greater than the number itself you know
if you took two to the third power
that's greater than two three to the
third power is greater than three you
know one and a half to the third power
is greater than one and a half so we
know that this this statement right here
implies that x
is greater than one
and let's see are there any is there any
negative is there a situation where x
can be negative
well let's see if x first of all if x is
between zero and one
x if x is between zero and one
let's see if you have one half one half
is not less than 1 8. so it doesn't work
between 0 and 1 but what if you went
between
x is what if x were between negative 1
and 0
let's try example if you have
negative one-half is is less than
negative one-eighth it's more negative
right negative one-half is negative
one-half
is less than negative one-eighth right
and you could try that with any fraction
because when you take the third power it
becomes a smaller fraction because it
becomes a smaller negative fraction so x
will be less than it because it's more
negative
so this is so this is true so right now
this statement applies if this is true
then x is either greater than one or
it's between negative one and zero
and let's see does it work if x is less
than negative one
negative two is negative two less than
negative eight nope
right so this is these are the only
ranges where it works
this statement implies this but this
still isn't enough information to tell
us whether x is less than zero x could
be greater than one which is definitely
greater than zero or x could be less
than zero so we don't know yet just from
statement one statement two
statement two tells us
x squared minus one
is less than zero
so add one to both sides that tells us
that x squared
is less than
one
so when because something squared going
to be less than 1
what's going to have to be between
negative 1
it's going to have to be neg between
negative 1 and 1
right it's essentially going to have to
be a positive or a negative fraction
less than one that's the only way that
when you square it you get a number less
than one
right if it was greater than one you're
definitely going to get a number greater
than one
and it's going to be positive either way
and if you get if it's one it's going to
be one and then zero is in our range so
statement two tells us this but it
includes both positive and negative
numbers so it doesn't answer our
question whether x was less than zero
but if we use both statements combined
right what is the intersection what is
the overlap of this and this
well if x has to has to be between
negative one and one
and it has to be one of these
right the only one that it overlaps with
is this one
you cannot have x being greater than 1
and
x being in this range
you can have x being in this range and x
being in this range since this is a
subset of this
so
this is actually the more restrictive
and so since we go to that that actually
tells us that x has to be negative so
both statements combined are sufficient
to answer this question but individually
they're not
the last question 155
marsha's bucket can hold a maximum of
how many liters of water so we want to
know the capacity of her bucket
the capacity of her bucket
statement number one says the bucket
currently contains nine liters of water
that's useless we don't know how i mean
you know that could be the bucket nine
liters could be that or maybe nine
liters is the full capacity that tells
us nothing about what the capacity of
the bucket is you know i if i told you i
had a bag of the sandwich that tells you
nothing as far as how large of a
sandwich i can eat so statement one is
doesn't seem that useful
statement two if three liters of water
three liters of water are added to the
bucket when it is half full of water
so
one half
times the capacity right when it's half
full of water
you add three liters so if three liters
of water are added to the bucket when it
is half full of water
the amount of water in the
the amount of water in the bucket will
increase by one-third
so that is equal to
so to increase
so that is equal to to increase
something by one-third
that is
like multiplying it by one and one third
right that's one and one third
times the capacity
that's what they're saying
right right the amount of water in the
bucket will increase by one so they're
essentially saying if you start off with
i don't know sorry you're going to have
one and one third times what you started
off with which was half your capacity
which was half your capacity that makes
sense we say we're starting with half of
our capacity and we're adding three
liters
we're adding three liters and they're
saying that that will increase the
amount we have
by one and one third let me write that
let's say we start with
we start with
i don't know x and we're adding three
liters you're saying that will equal one
and one third or four thirds times x
right
this this shows that x is increasing by
one third
you could view this as one plus one
third
times x this is an increase of 1 3.
and they tell us that
our starting point is half of capacity
so that's where i get the one half c
that's our starting point plus 3 is
equal to 4 3 times the starting point or
where we're adding water to one half
times c and we could easily solve for c
here so you get a two this cancels out
and then you get
one half c
plus three is equal to two thirds c
and let's see we could subtract c from
one half c from both sides and you get
three is equal to two thirds minus one
half
c
and then you could just do that fact
fraction and you get c is equal to 3
over well
what is this one half so if you do it
over 6
4
minus 3. so this is 1 6
so this turns into 1 6
so c
is equal to
18.
but anyway you didn't have to do all
that you should just realize that as
soon as you can write this albert
algebraic equation down it's a linear
equation with one unknown and that one
unknown is what we're trying to solve
for you have enough information to solve
the problem so statement c sorry
statement 2 alone is sufficient to solve
this problem and we're all done with
data sufficiency see all in the next
section